[Music]
welcome back to next episode of what's
up Roth hello Walter hello again it's
nice to see you I see you too often
these days it's becoming a habit it's
becoming average you're right I'll open
up forward with a word of prayer it'll
be nice
how are you father thank you very much
for once again bringing us together we
ask that you bless this gathering and do
bless also the people that listen and
watch the video in Jesus name I mean
amen so in the previous episode you
mentioned that we have to talk about the
shaking now can you give us an
introduction because a lot of people
might not know what you meant by a
shaking yes now we did have a what's up
proof 1 on the spirit of prophecy but I
specifically thought it would be prudent
to talk about the shaking as well now
why will there be a shaking and you know
some of the comments that we got seem to
suggest that seventh-day adventists or
rather of Stier what's the matter with
them why they're so fussy about eating
and drinking you know is God gonna worry
about all of those things and surely is
not going to be concerned about you know
what goes into your stomach and all of
these issues but I would just like to
remind the viewers that in Old Testament
times and God has not changed he was
very exact and he was very strict and
under those circumstances which was a
theocracy where God was the ultimate
ruler and where the served as a typology
for a greater reality if you transgress
God's law the punishment was death now
we know that Christ ultimately took that
punishment upon himself
but the wages of sin is death and if you
go back into Old Testament times take
the blessings and the cursings so they
were read the people were divided into
two groups standing on two hills and the
blessings and the cursings who were read
and if they departed from the ways of
the Lord then even though it was long
suffering the cursings
were sure to follow he also said to them
that should they not return and make
right they will go into banishment and
they will be taken away and and their
nation will be taken away and they said
this'll never happen we are the chosen
people of God this will never happen but
it happened it happened to the Northern
Kingdom it happened to the to the
southern kingdom happen to Judah so God
is very exact
he's long-suffering but exact and he
repeatedly sent prophets to admonish
them were they very excited about the
prophets and said wonderful that you
were coming to admonish us no they were
anything bad Ryan history they were very
very angry and they treated the prophets
shamefully some of them they stoned some
of them they swallowed enough like
Isaiah and I think as I was going to be
very surprised to see the man that
ordered him to be soul enough in heaven
because he repented right Manasseh
but the issue of God's admonishments and
the consequences of the neglect thereof
or just as real today as they were in
those days now we discussed the spirit
of prophecy
not a very named spirit of prophecy and
what she wrote was called testimonies to
the church these are terms which are
rooted in in the Bible and we need to
understand how God worked in the past
through prophets to ascertain whether we
have a prophet in the days that we are
living in so let's have a look at some
of the verses in the Bible and see if we
can find some parallels and then ask
ourselves again the question what
happened when the Israelites ignored
their prophets they suffered the
consequences reached and what happened
when they obeyed and followed and
repented blessings rise so we're in the
same situation and we are no better
in fact we're probably a good deal worse
than the Israelites were so let's go to
the Bible and have a look at this topic
the gift of prophecy and the shaking in
2nd Peter 1 verse 21 we read for
prophecy came not in old times by the
will of man but holy men of God spake as
they were moved by the Holy Ghost
so prophecy in the past was not the word
of man it was the Word of God so it was
very important that you listened because
this was God speaking through a person
not all prophets were canonical not all
were taken up in the Bible Nathan for
example was a prophet and Holda was a
prophet so there were many prophets is
many prophets that are mentioned in the
Bible but don't have a book or there's
no writings of them no take the
daughters of Philip there were prophets
now this word testimony is interesting
word isaiah 8 verse 22 the law that's
the first five books of the Bible the
Torah and to the testimony if they speak
not according to this word it is because
there is no light in them this just
tells us that what
prophet says must be in harmony with the
Bible yes but the testimony is as much
the Word of God as theirs the law the
Torah in Revelation chapter 1 John tells
us that he was on this island and he
writes who bare record of the word of
God that's basically the law and of the
testimony of Jesus Christ and of all
things that he saw so here is a prophet
and he's talking about the testimony I
John who also am your brother is one of
us and companion in tribulation and in
the kingdom and patience of Jesus Christ
was in the isle that is called Patmos
for the word of God you have that aspect
and for the testimony of Jesus Christ so
this is Jesus Christ Himself revealing
his will to the prophet and the Prophet
reveals his will to the people
revelation 19:10 this verse we dealt
with under the spirit of prophecy and I
fell at his feet and worshiped him
verses where the angel comes to John and
he was overwhelmed and he said unto me
see thou do it not for I am thy
fellow-servant and of thy brethren that
have the testimony of Jesus in other
words they have the special gift worship
God for the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of prophecy so they have the word
spirit of prophecy
so testimony and spirit of prophecy or
very biblical terms so the word
testimony occurs 73 times in the Bible
and it refers to what God had
communicated to his people either by
writing it himself as in the case of the
law for ten commandments or by
communicating it to his prophets so if
we go to Exodus chapter 25 verse 21
and thou shalt put the mercy seat above
upon the ark and in the ark thou shall
put the testimony that I shall give thee
so here's the word testimony it refers
to God's instructions God's Word there
was to be placed inside the Ark well
verse 18 in Exodus 31 and he gave unto
Moses when he had made an end of
communing with him upon Mount Zion two
tables of testimony tables of stone
written with the finger of God so when
we talking about testimony to the church
it's a very important thing it is the
Word of God
Psalm 132 verse 12 says if thy children
will keep my covenant and my testimony
so all of these words or parallel
phrases but the word testimony refers to
the special spoken instruction for God's
people that I shall teach them their
children shall also set upon thy throne
forevermore so here's the promise if you
stick to what God has said and to the
testimonies which are for your own good
not because God is some harsh taskmaster
but because this is how you are designed
this is for your own benefit yes and
we've so far fallen from the original
that sometimes we don't even realize in
what state we are in but God knows so he
sends us testimonies it's like we said
also in a previous episode it's also
almost as if when God says something we
are dismayed
but when Satan has his way then we feel
good then everybody says well this seems
to be the right way right as ayat verse
16 bind up the testimony seal the law
amongst my disciples so this is what
God's will is in our law
that we should make the testimony which
he has given through his prophets part
and parcel of our life the Prophet is
someone who brings testimonies to the
church here's a quote from prophets and
kings in his testimonies to the church
jeremiah constantly referred to the
teachings of the book of the law that
had been so greatly honoured and exalted
during Josiah's reign he emphasized the
knew the importance of maintaining a
covenant relationship with the old
merciful and compassionate being who
upon the heights of sinai had spoken the
precepts of the Decalogue Jeremiah's
words of warning and entreaty reached
every part of the kingdom and all had
opportunity to know the will of God
concerning the nation that's what a
testimony is for now as we've already
mentioned Jeremiah's testimony wasn't
very welcome in fact when the
Babylonians came he was in jail and it's
interesting that the Babylonians
released him and said he can go and what
happened to the others they were taken
they were taken so God showed that his
word stands so prophet predicts the
future or he writes about the past like
Moses did for example when he went back
into history and he's looked back in
time and he's looked forward to the
coming deliverer both inspired by God
because it's a testimony and it's the
Word of God so a prophet brings reproof
either personally in public documents or
in private letters take the Bible yeah
correct what appalls letters also know
what about 1 John 2 John and 3 John
those are letters
those are personal letters in the Bible
so those personal letters when spy it
obviously they were taken up into the
Canon so can a personal letter that our
prophet writes to someone be the
inspired Word of God yes you believe and
the Bible shows me soon okay so we have
it in the Bible so why shouldn't it also
be extra biblical right when Nathan
spoke many words to David that are not
recorded surely they were inspired yes
the question is what is inspired and
what is not inspired how do you
distinguish because people want
loopholes
I want to get out of it somehow so let's
go to the end times and we see that God
in the end has also promised the
prophetic gift revelation 12 verse 17
and the dragon was wroth with the woman
the church and went to make war with the
remnant of her seed that's the lost
church on earth and the attributes we've
discussed this many time were they keep
the commandments of God and they have
the testimony of Jesus Christ
yes in other words the prophetic word
they must be a prophet in the lost
church it's biblical revelation 19:10
and I fell at his feet to worship Him
and he said unto me see that thou do it
not for I am thy fellow-servant of the
brethren that have the testimony of
Jesus worship God then can that
definition we've added on the screen
before for the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of prophecy
so the remnant Church has the spirit of
prophecy now according to what we have
seen whose word is that God's Word God's
Word even though it's not written in the
Bible if it is a true prophet yes
because there's political criteria that
you can taste the prophet too right now
we've discussed that and a
previous one and we've come to the
conclusion that there is such a profit
now we believe that LNG white had the
gift of prophecy we've discussed that
you can put that link in again I think
and how do we deal with this this is
profit going to be popular well if you
look at the history I doubt it
okay so here's the Catholic Herald from
ninth January 2020 and they declared
Ellen White the heretic of the week now
this word heretic is of course a word
that occurs just once in the Bible and
it's a direct transliteration of the
Greek and I gave a sermon on that issue
once okay bookends I'll put the links
into that soon put that link in so that
we can see what is this word heretic
mean because our dictionaries have got a
dead wrong because they've been so
indoctrinated that they have a dead
wrong you can only get the definition if
it occurs only once in the Bible from
the Bible so what did they write they
said the eighteen thirties were
tempestuous time for American
Protestantism from the files of the
second great awakening to the ongoing
march of unitarianism adding to the
general excitement the self-described
biblical prophet William Ella that's not
true no because nobody said he was a
prophet no especially himself came up
with two dates for doomsday in that
fraud Dec decade when neither eventuated
melody cleared himself a failure and
retired from the prophecy business now
that is such a gross distortion and I
would I would like you to put a link in
conflict and triumph
I know you've put it in before but I'll
do it again but conflict and triumph is
a series which shows how God has
gathered all the great truths through
the centuries and put them into a
package deal for the end time please I
think I think people really should study
that or get the true historical picture
absolutely absolutely not this distorted
type of no not this kind of information
that we have here his followers were
much dismayed by their great
disappointment many returned I wonder
whether decide whether the disciples
were much dismayed by their a great
disappointment when Jesus died on the
cross yes many returned to the
denominations from which they had come
many more join the Shakers now they also
had a profit at that time in fact there
were many profits that appeared at that
time and we don't have to go into the
details because we've done it before
right but a remnant it's interesting
that they used that word rival retained
the faith in Mela that Malay himself
lacked know they retained the faith in
the scriptures that Mela stumbled upon
at the head of many of these emerged L&G
white and native of Maine shortly after
Miller's second issues
she received the first of more than
2,000 visitations she claimed to have
been from Christ she was able to inspire
many of the remaining Adventists as
Miller's remaining followers called
themselves with a new vision her ongoing
revelations formed the basis of the
doctrine upon which she and her husband
James founded the seventh-day Adventist
Church so-called because white claimed
that Christ wanted to be worshiped on
the Jewish Sabbath that is the most
ridiculous statement I've
red God Himself says it over and over
and over in the Bible you don't need
James and you don't need Ellen White to
tell you that you need the scriptures so
this is a derogatory statement because
they themselves are in transgression yes
these doctrines included the revival of
Jewish dietary customs
although most Adventists of vegetarian
today well they have that partly correct
identification of the Pope as Antichrist
that must act them was it only the
Adventists that identified him as
Antichrist know all the Reformers do all
the Reformers did so this is a
Reformation movement in fact it is the
remnant of the Reformation movement
because those reformers all those
churches that claim to be based on the
Reformers no longer believe what the
Reformers thought and why did the
Reformers teacher did they grab it out
of a hat that series of yours Crete to
Malta you discuss way and also darkness
before dawn that shows beautifully how
Protestantism has fallen and doesn't
teach what they do did during the
Reformation any more things before dawn
Lincoln there as well so three separate
divine persons rather than the Orthodox
doctrine of Trinity now what is the
Orthodox doctrine of Trinity if you
study the Catholic Trinity it is a
pantheistic Trinity that is why you need
all of these human into positions right
whereas in the Bible you have a direct
communication with the Sun which they
deny you have to go through Mary or the
priest in fact in one of their
statements they say nobody comes to the
Father except by Mary and nobody comes
to Mary except by the church
but if you have a personal guard you go
directly to God through Jesus Christ for
the most part Adventists are
conscientious objectors but they have
specialized in medical roles during
wartime it was a interesting similarly
the denomination has a generous
commitment to hospitals and schools and
were great practitioners of racial
equality we've got that right there
technological savvy must be balanced
against the proof asserted of the papers
papers is diabolical nature that the
non-existent ex-criminal inscription on
the papal tiara adds up to 666 in Hebrew
letters I you know what there's a
marvelous book by the edwin the
cork 666 or the antichrist perhaps you
can put a reference to his book in there
which shows very clearly that this is
not a non-existent issue at all so on
the one hand you have the world and the
great roman catholic system saying that
ln g white is a heretic and well then
she is in very good company because
Martin Luther was a heretic Wickliffe
was a heretic John HUS was aware a
heretic you didn't go through the entire
list of the Reformers they were all
heretics according to them and that link
on book ends will show that if this is
the definition of a heretic I gladly I'm
a heretic too yes so let's have a look
at some of the comparisons between John
the Baptist and L&G what she writes the
Prophet John was the connecting link
between two dispensations as God's
representative he stood forth to show
the relation of the law and the prophets
to the Christian dispenser
it's very important was the less
relationship of the Old Testament
covenant to the new covenant how does it
relate and then he writes he was the
lesser light which was to be followed by
a greater it's interesting that she's
also referred to as a lesser light which
points to the greater light which is the
Bible so the two have to be in harmony
to the law and to the testimony right
the mind of John was illuminated by the
holy spirit that he might shed light
upon his people but no other light ever
has shone or ever will shine so clearly
upon fallen man as that which emanated
from the teaching and example of Jesus
Christ and his mission had been but
dimly understood as stupefied in the
shadow he sacrifices even John had not
fully comprehended the future immortal
life through the Savior because even
from prison he asked are you the one or
do we wait for another and that after he
baptized Jesus and saw the Holy Ghost
the Saint on him and heard the voice of
God say this is my beloved son
absolutely but we have some interesting
parallels it was a lesser light pointing
to the greater life he must increase I
must decrease the Lord has sent his
people are talking about the testimonies
for our time the Lord has sent his
people much instruction line upon line
precept upon precept here a little and
there a little little heed is given to
the Bible and the Lord has given a
lesser light this is now the spirit of
prophecy alone why to lead men and women
to the greater light oh how much good
would be accomplished if the books
containing this light were read with a
determination to carry out the
principles they contain there would be a
thousandfold greater vigilance
a thousandfold more self-denial and
resolute effort and many more would now
be rejoicing in the light of present
truth I love this is absolute blatant
arrogance what's true great and the
proof of the pudding is in the eating
is in the eating so how do we look at
the spirit of prophecy Matthew chapter
11 verse seventh says and as they
departed Jesus began to say unto the
multitudes concerning Jordan what went
ye out into the wilderness to see a reed
shaken with the wind but what went you
out to see a man clothed in soft raiment
behold they that were soft clothing are
in King's houses but what went ye out to
see three times the AUSA's interesting a
prophet yea I say unto you and more than
a prophet why was he more than a prophet
for this is he of whom it is written
behold I send my messenger before thy
face which shall prepare thy way before
thee so here was someone who was more
than a prophet he was a messenger for a
specific purpose to prepare the way for
the coming of Jesus yes so imagine if
this was essential in the time of Jesus
at his first coming
wouldn't it be essential at his second
coming
wouldn't he send someone who would be
more than a prophet in the sense of
being a messenger to prepare God's
people for the second coming of Christ
so this was a type and he had the spirit
of prophecy and he was the lesser light
pointing to the greater light he must
increase I must
now what about Ellen White what is she
right here she says during the discourse
I said that I did not claim to be a
prophetess some were surprised at this
statement and as much is being said in
regard to it I will make an explanation
others have called me a prophetess but I
have never assumed that title I have not
felt that it was my duty thus to decide
myself those who boldly assume that
there are prophets in this our day are
often a reproach to the cause of Christ
so this is a humble statement but then
she clarifies it you know I just want to
say a lot of people stopped me they stop
there and say okay she is not a prophet
right she says my work includes much
more than this name signifies I regard
myself as a messenger what was John the
Baptist a messenger and was he more than
a prophet yes why because he had a
specific task which was so specific he
had to prepare a people for the divine
presence amongst them so he was a
messenger entrusted by the Lord with
messages for his people and so was she
I now instructed that I'm not to be
hindered in my work by those who engage
in suppositions regarding its nature
whose minds are struggling with so many
intricate problems connected with the
supposed work of a prophet my Commission
embraces the work of a prophet but it
does not end there it embraces much more
than the minds of those who have been
sowing the seeds of unbelief can
comprehend so John the Baptist was more
than a prophet and he was a lesser life
she was more than a prophet
she was the lesser life he was a
messenger she was a messenger he was
preparing for the coming of Jesus and
she was preparing for the coming of
Jesus
the gift of prophecy has to be an
integral part of the remnant now surely
if God worked in a specific way in the
past by raising up specific prophets he
will work in the same fashion at the end
of time so either this is so or it is
not so and should we be ashamed because
there is a prophet well obviously
because many people think oh you know
there are so many false prophets we want
nothing to do with this but what if it's
true
so even is true could it form an
integral part of the final events so I
thought it was necessary that we speak
about the shaking what will cause the
shaking now the shaking is something
that is perplexing because it implies
that people will be shaken up and God's
people just like the Israelites of old
are not necessarily prepared for the
second coming of Christ correct and
there are statements which says not one
in 20 is ready for the coming of the
Lord the parable of the ten virgins also
tells you exactly a church is not ready
not just not ready so let's have a look
at this concept of the shaking
particularly in the light of some of the
issues we've been speaking about in this
series and the way in which people
reacted tells me that they do not have
the confidence in the spirit of prophecy
that they should have so let's have a
look at this I asked the meaning of the
shaking that she had seen and I was
shown that it would be caused by the
straight testimony now there's the name
again called forth by the counsel of the
true witness to the Lord since the
latter census the last church
and the true witness who is the true
witness Jesus Christ is the true witness
and the testimony of Jesus is what they
have so that let's rephrase this
sentence because it's written in very
biblical language let's rephrase it I
saw that it was caused by the testimony
of the true witness to the Lord Syrians
in other words it was called the
testimony given by Jesus Christ to the
remnant the testimony will cause the
shaking this will have its effect upon
lots of the receiver and will lead him
to exalt the standard and pour forth the
straight truth some will not bear this
straight testimony so if you quote it
you can get into trouble and they will
rise up against it and this is what will
cause a shaking amongst God's people I
saw that the testimony of the true
witness this is not out of context it's
the next paragraph right yes has not
been half heeded the solemn testimony
upon which the destiny of the church
hangs has been lightly esteemed if not
entirely disregarded this testimony must
work deep repentance all who truly
receive it well obey it and be purified
so in other words an acceptance of the
instructions given through the
testimonies will determine whether you
are shaken out or not yes so what it
says that's what it says are you sure
yes that's a serious business it is it's
an incredibly serious business all right
so what is this entail the number of
this company had lessened
so she was shown envision what would
happen if you do not accept the
testimonies the number of the company
had listened there was a shaking some
had been shaken out and left by the way
the careless and indifferent who did not
join with those who prized victory and
salvation enough to perseveringly plead
and agonize for it did not obtain it and
they were left behind in darkness and
their places were immediately felt by
others taking hold of the truth and
coming into the ranks now lets us be
absolutely horrifying to think that you
have known the church you have known the
biblical truths that it entails and
preaches but because you've never made
it your own you could be shaken up and
somebody could take your place evil
angels still pressed around them but
could have no power over them now the
Lord calls for every newel of the
straight testimony in other words if
this gift in the church is neglected God
calls for a renewal of it as born in the
past years he calls for a renewal of
spiritual life the spiritual energies of
his people have long been torpid but
there is to be a resurrection from
apparent death by prayer and confession
of sin we must clear the Kings Highway
you always hear we have to have revival
in the church yes according to what we
just read this is how you get it so in
other words revival is not based on a
bedlam of noise not on how many times
you can pass a drum yes no no I mean in
lights you've got on the stage or how
had masks appears on the stage or how
the lights are dimmed in other words
that which will produce a revived
would be confession of sin prayer and
that will clear the Kansai renewal of
the straight testimony and renewal of
the straight testimony which is the
spirit of prophecy so what does it mean
to be sealed well just as soon as the
people of God are sealed in therefore it
it is not any seal or mark that can be
seen but a sickling into the truth both
intellectually and spiritually so they
cannot be moved now how do you settle
into the truth by experience you have to
study the word you have to realize this
is really what God requires of me you
must say to God Lord help me to achieve
this and it must become part of your
life yes it must be like putting your
clothes on in the morning you don't go
walking in the streets naked right you
put your clothes on the mosque on these
days that's true yes you must you must
eat without it though
I actually saw these some people that
would have won that they can open they
can open all right okay
so just as soon as God's people are
sealed
in other words settled in the truth so
that they cannot be moved and prepared
for the shaking it will come indeed it
has begun already and the judgments of
God are now upon the land to give us
warning that we may know what is coming
so we need to be settled in the truth in
other words if you go back to ancient
Israel they for long periods of time
neglected God's truths right and they
went way off the mark they were on a
totally different track and then at some
stage somebody would clean up with the
tempo and find this dusty book of the
law and come out
say we found it the book of the law and
they would read and some would say oh
they would tear their clothes and
profess tameria to say Lord we departed
so far from your ways is this what it's
supposed to happen here I think so
I think so too I was shown that the
testimony to the lauded science applies
to God's people at the present time and
the reason it has not accomplished a
greater work is because of the hardness
of their hearts but God has given the
missed message time to do its work now
this is very important we don't see God
obliterating those who aren't following
the guidelines right he leaves them but
God has given the message time to do its
work the heart must be purified from
sins which have so long shut out Jesus
this fearful message will do its work
when it was first presented it led to
close examination of heart
sins were confessed and the people of
God was stirred everywhere nearly all
believed that this message would end in
the loud cry of the third angel but as
they failed to see the powerful work
accomplished in a short time many lost
the effect of the message I saw that
this message would not accomplish its
work in a few short months it is
designed to arouse God's people to
discover to them their backslidings and
to lead to zealous repentance there's
always this word that they may be
favored with the presence of Jesus and
be fitted for the loud cry of the third
angel as this message affected our heart
it led to deep humility before God
angels were sent in every direction to
prepare unbelieving hearts for the truth
so in order to be qualified to bring the
loud cry there needs to be again
repentance the cause of God began to
rise and his people were acquainted with
their position if the counsel of the
true witness had been fully heeded this
is again testimonies to the church that
we're referring to here God would have
wrought for his people in great power
yet the efforts made since the message
has been given have been blessed of God
and many souls have been brought from
error and darkness to rejoice in the
truth yes there have been conversions
and yes the church has grown but the
work is not done
God will prove his people Jesus bears
patiently with them and does not spew
them out of his mouth in a moment but
the promise is there is it doesn't mean
that he's not gonna do it at all
correct said the angel God is weighing
his people if the message had been of as
short duration as many of us suppose
there would have been no time for them
to develop character many moved from
feeling not from principle and faith and
the solemn fearful message stirred them
it wrought upon their feelings and
excited their fears but did not
accomplish the work which God designed
to Richard God reads the heart lest his
people should be deceived in regard to
themselves he gives them time for the
excitement to wear off and they improves
them to see if they will pay the counsel
of the true witness so if we go to the
various churches today is the majority
paying the counsel of the true witness
unfortunately not
it's the minority erroneous and if you
go to the Bible and it talks about the
shaking it talks to the Prophet and it
says shake shake the garment and then
take a portion of that and shake that
out and then take a portion and shake
that out and the Prophet says
nobody left this is a serious issue and
I'm wondering whether it isn't time that
the church started looking at this and
saying to itself isn't it time that we
took a serious look at the Council of
the to witness and say to ourselves is
this meant for me must I make a change
to my life
said the angel God will bring his work
closer and closer to test and prove
every one of his people some are willing
to receive one point but God brings them
to another testing point they shrink
from it and stand back because they find
that it strikes directly at some
cherished Idol that's most of the time
our own problems
that's our own problem because even in
the Bible and the testimonies there's
always this little thing that when it
gets spoken of you want to I I want to
keep on to this yes exactly so in other
words you don't want to give up your
cherished little idol whether it be
something dietary or whether it be a
habit or whether it be a nasty
temperament that you have and our excuse
usually is God knows my heart you will
he will he will gloss it over I wonder
if he glossed over the small taste that
he put to our first parents that is true
that is true he didn't gloss over that
small little taste at all that luxury
that surrounded them and maybe God's
people need in the time that we live in
to take a closer look at these issues
here they have opportunity to see what
is in their hearts that shuts out Jesus
they price something higher than the
truth and their hearts are not prepared
to receive Jesus individuals are tested
and proved a length of time to see if
they will sacrifice their idols and heat
the counsel of the true witness again
and again
this terminology appears if any will not
be purified through obeying the truth
and overcome their selfishness their
pride and evil passions there are so
many people that are addicted to
television and they think it is harmless
but all those images that constantly
flash before your mind just are so
seductive and there are worse things to
watch on the internet and many many
people will need to do serious
introspection and ask God to help them
to get over this they are joined to the
idols let them alone is eventually the
final condemnation and they pass on to
their work leaving these with their
sinful trace unsubdued to the control of
evil angels this is what the Angels keep
shot of God gave charge leave them it
can be let them be it's sad as a sad
statement that's a sad stead we need on
a daily basis to say to God help me to
be in harmony with your world and if I
have a selfish tray help me you give it
up those who come up to every point and
stand every test and overcome be the
price what it may have heeded the
counsel of the true witness is there any
half measure here well God gloss over
some things and not others and they will
receive the latter rain and thus be
fitted for translation you know I come
to many many churches and even you know
general proclamations we need to pray
for the latter rain we can pray for the
latter rain until we are blue in the
face if we do not heed the council we
will not receive the latter rain so
there are drops of latter rain falling
in the world but their art falling will
come when the church takes the counsel
of the true witness seriously
let the testimonies be judged by their
fruits what is the spirit of their
teaching what has been the result of
their influence all we desired to do so
can acquaint themselves with the fruits
of these visions God is either teaching
his church reproving their wrongs and
strengthening their faith or is not this
work is of God or it is not God does
nothing in partnership with Satan my
work bears the stamp of God or the stamp
of the enemy there is no halfway work in
the matter you know we always want a
half way work I wonder whether this is
an opinion of us or whether this inspire
inspired the testimonies of the Spirit
of God or they are of the devil that is
putting it in a nutshell
absolutely perilous times are before us
everyone who has a knowledge of the
truth should awake and place himself
body soul and spirit under the
discipline of God how do I know what God
requires it is spelled out in the spirit
of prophecy it is in plain words
absolutely nobody can say I can't
understand this we must put on the whole
armor of God we must follow the
directions given through the spirit of
prophecy that's pretty straightforward
we must follow the direction given
through the spirit of prophecy we must
love and obey the truth for this time
other people will say oh they're putting
energy right above the Bible no this is
explaining what God required in the past
and that God will require exactly the
same thing in the future and in the
present if the spirit of prophecy if the
Prophet is in harmony and with the Bible
and to be declared a prophet she has to
be absolutely oh she's not a prophet
then if she writes to tell you if you
say some of the things in the Bible are
hard to understand
then it's like plain yeah there's no
body that can say that it's not I don't
understand
what God has actually said and this is a
bit more difficult we must love and obey
the truth for this time now you know
what when you make these changes they're
hard but once you've actually done it
you you love it I could go back to my
old lifestyle Holland to me and you said
exactly the same thing so how do you get
to love something by practicing it it's
the same way with people when you're
dealing with people you have to get used
to dealing with people nicely if you
weren't used to it before yes and
afterwards you can't think that you've
dealt with people any different than you
exactly so this will save us from
accepting strong delusions God has
spoken to us through his word he has
spoken to us through the testimonies to
the church and through the books that
have helped to make plain our present
duty and the position that we should now
occupy so how do we know what we should
do he spoken us through his word he
spoken us through the testimonies to the
church he spoken us through the books
and he's made it very plain the warnings
that have been given a line upon line
precept upon precept should be heeded if
we disregard them what excuse can we
offer I beseech those who are labouring
for God not to accept the spurious for
the genuine let not human reason to be
placed where divine sanctifying truth
should be Christ is waiting to Kindle
faith and love in the heart of his
people let not erroneous theories
receive countenance from the people who
ought to be standing on the platform of
eternal truth God calls upon us to hold
firmly to the fundamental principles
that have been based upon unquestionable
Authority so if I have a pet theory and
I find that it is in contradiction with
a spirit of prophecy and I study the
Bible and the spirit
prophecy together then I must come to
the conclusion that I must give up my
pet theory because it's not in harmony
with God like we said in that episode
about the spirit of prophecy if there's
something that you read in the
testimonies and it doesn't make sense
and instead of saying this is a false
prophet you must ask why don't I
understand what is is saying it's said
here and then do further study on that
subject
absolutely yeah I'm so proud of you I
was shown that if God's people make no
effort on their part but wait for the
refreshing to come upon them and remove
their wrongs and correct their errors if
they depend upon that to cleanse them
from filthiness of the flesh and spirit
and fit them to engage in the loud cry
of the third angel they will be found
wanting
there's going to be no special magic
wand that will be waived to correct what
you could have corrected before the
refreshing or power of God comes only on
those who have prepared themselves for
it by doing the work with God fits them
namely cleansing themselves from all
filthiness of the flesh and spirit
perfecting holiness in the fear of God
this is very common is the remnant
people of God must be a converted people
it's not a good enough to know the truth
it must be applied to the heart the
presentation of this message is to
result in the conversion and
sanctification of souls we are to feel
the power of the Spirit of God in this
movement this is a wonderful definite
message it means everything to the
receiver and it is to proclaimed with a
loud cry we must have a true abiding
faith that this message will go forth
with increasing importance till the
close of time no matter how much
opposition there is if we stand on this
foundation then it will swell to a loud
cry now
the sphere of prophecy hasn't always
been accepted and even within the church
in fact that is where it is probably
more elective neglected that in many
places outside the church and there's an
interesting book that used to be
prescribed at our colleges of the past
and I wish it were still the case it's
called the spirit of prophecy treasure
chest and it has a little message from
you from sister white with our own
signature on it
we are homeward bound a little longer
and the strife will be over may we you
stand in the heat of the conflict ever
keep before us a vision of things unseen
you know what this is so important to
understand that we are surrounded by
angels and by evil angels and that there
is a constant conflict if we do not
understand the conflict there will be
many many pains that we will endure
because we do not recognize it in the
context if we know that we are fighting
not against flesh and blood then we will
be on our knees far more than we
actually are
that time when the world will be bathed
in the light of heaven when the years
will move in gladness when over the
scenes the morning stars will sing
together and the sons of God will shout
for joy while God and Christ will unite
in proclaiming there shall be no more
sin neither shall there be any more
death forgetting those things which are
behind and reaching forth unto those
things which are before let us press
towards the mark for the prize of the
high calling of God in Christ Jesus this
is our mission now let's have a look at
some of the statements that reflect on
this manuscript she writes I gave myself
my
being to God to obey his call in
everything and since that time my life
has been spent in giving the message
with pen and in speaking before large
congregations it is not I who control my
words and actions at such times in other
words she says God is the one that takes
control but there are times when common
things must be stated common thoughts
must occupy the mind common letters must
be written and information given that is
passed from one to another of the
workers such words such information are
not given under the special inspiration
of the Spirit of God questions are asked
at times that are not upon religious
subjects at all and these questions must
be answered we converse about houses and
lands and trades to be made and
locations for institutions the
advantages and disadvantages so is
everything inspired no but what is
inspired because it's so easy to say
well that's probably an opinion yes so
we need to be very clear as to what is
inspired and what is an opinion and what
is just common language common
discussion so what does she say about
her books cuz I want to know what is
inspired know what is not right yes so
wouldn't you know definitely because
that will sort out a lot of illusion
absolutely
since the white is not the originator of
these books so who is let's find out
they contain the instruction that during
her life work God has been giving her so
that it is originated ah God is the
originator they contain the precious
comforting light that God has graciously
given his servant to be given to the
world so this is a prophet being used by
God from their pages this light is to
shine into the hearts of
leading them to the savior the Lord has
declared that these books are to be
scattered throughout the world there is
in them truth which to the receiver is a
savour of life unto life they are silent
witnesses for God in the past they have
been the means in his hands of
convicting and converting many souls
many have read them with eager
expectation and by reading them have
been led to see the efficacy of Christ's
atonement and to trust in its power they
have been led to commit the keeping of
their souls to their Creator waiting and
hoping for the coming of the Savior to
take his loved ones to the eternal home
in the future these books are to make
the gospel plain to many others
revealing to them the way of salvation
the books are inspired and to be given
to the world now can we be a little bit
daring yet if she says for example in
the box that the world is about six
thousand years old does that mean it is
about ten thousand years old no I don't
think so does it mean it's millions of
years old does it mean six thousand a
thousand in other words is that
something that came from the influence
of a bishop Asha or was it inspiration
of God if the books are inspired it
should be inspired by God so it must be
so whether we believe the one or whether
we believe the other it depends on our
faith in the spirit of prophecy right so
what is not inspired
well biographical data and common
transactions of land etc are not
necessarily inspired but books
periodicals testimonies spirit of
prophecy volumes for example other than
the biographical portions are inspired
so God has given me a marked solemn
experience in connection with his work
and you may be assured that so long as
my life is spared
I shall not cease to lift a warning
voice as I'm impressed by the Spirit of
God where the men will hear or whether
they will forbear I have no special
wisdom in myself I am only an instrument
in the Lord's hand to do the work he has
set for me to do the instructions that I
have given by pen or voice have been an
expression of the life that God has
given me I've tried to place before you
the principles that the Spirit of God
has for years been impressing upon my
mind and writing upon my hearts and now
brethren I entreat you not to interpose
between me and the people and turn away
the light which God would have come to
them do not by your criticism take out
all the force all the point and power
from the testimonies do not feel that
you can distinct them to suit your own
ideas claiming that God has given you
ability to discern what is light from
heaven and what is the expression of
mere human wisdom we have us all the
time people say what she was influenced
by this that and the other ladies from
God what is not and if we start this
detecting then we will not know where we
stand
in the stream of time either if the
testimony speak not according to the
Word of God reject them Christ and
billy-oh cannot be united for Christ's
sake do not confuse the minds of the
people with human surface tree and
skepticism and make of none effect the
work that the Lord would do so once we
sought to sichting it and saying that
this was inspired and that was an
opinion then we are making it of non
effect or or if we say it doesn't have
authority
what will cause the shaking the straight
testimony I see do not by your lack of
spiritual discernment make of this agent
of God a rock of offense whereby many
shall be caused to stumble and fall and
be snared and be taken if God for
example through the spirit of prophecy
says that in the last days God's people
should follow a very specific diet and
you reject it you're rejecting the Word
of God rejecting the testimonies you're
rejecting the testimonies you might say
that this communication was only a
letter it was a letter but prompted by
the Spirit of God just like the letters
of John Paul to bring before your minds
things that have been shown me in these
letters which I write in the testimonies
I bear I am presenting to you that which
the Lord has presented to me I do not
write one article in the paper
expressing merely my own ideas they are
what God has opened before me envisioned
the precious rays of light shining from
the throne I have no special wisdom in
myself I'm only an instrument in the
Lord's hands to do the work he has set
before me to do the instructions that I
have given by pen or voice have been the
expression of the light that God has
given me I've tried to place before you
the principles of the Spirit of God has
for years been oppressing upon my mind
and writing on my heart and now to all
who have a desire for truth I would say
do not give credence to unauthenticated
reports as to what sister White has done
or said or written if you desire to know
what the Lord has revealed through her
read her published works are there any
points of interest concerning which she
has not written do not eagerly catch up
and report rumour
as to what she has said now in this
little book it has this little chapter
which is called a never to be forgotten
lesson and I thought it would be good to
share this I think it might be timely
there's a chapter letter attitudes
towards the gift unwittingly
a grave mistake made in the early 50s
this is talking about 1850 and not 1915
was destined to have rather far-reaching
effects on the cause of God during the
next five years so from 1850 to 1855
about a five year period there was a
grave mistake that was made through the
perplexing first six years of the
formative period the Lord had led in a
signal manner directing and protecting
the work through the spirit of prophecy
so after 1844 to 1850 God had led the
people through the testimonies and then
there was a perplexing error even so the
work had moved slowly
it was then next to impossible to obtain
access to unbelievers the disappointment
in 1840 forth had confused the minds of
many and they would not listen to any
explanation of the matter so people
didn't want to hear about these issues
but as we have already noted in an
earlier article the outlook had improved
by 1850 and 1851 so people were again
interested in the prophecies and the
world of the unbelievers were easy more
easily being reached correct and then
they made a decision and now the James
White could report now the door is open
almost everywhere to present truth and
many are prepared
to read the publications who have
formerly had no interest to investigate
so there was this publication the review
and Herald was sent out and people were
reading and they were interested now
what was the mistake with brighter
prospects for a large work amongst
unbelievers the general denominational
literature was shaped to meet the new
conditions the most noticeable
adjustment in this line was made to
avert prejudice and for this reason all
reference to the visions and the spirit
of prophecy was left out of the regular
issues of the church paper so when they
wrote to the public they totally left
out the spirit of prophecy
they sidelined it why huh it's hard for
people right yeah Bridget is multiple
people saying oh here's another prophet
we don't believe this this action was
explained by all the white in an extra
of the review and Herald made up largely
of early L&G white experiences and
visions here's the last page I wrote
this sheet is the form of the paper that
we hope to publish once in two weeks we
do not design this extra for so general
circulation as the regular paper so when
you refer to the spirit of prophecy said
we're not going to do that in the
regular paper for the reason that strong
prejudice prejudice exists in many minds
against a portion of its content so when
they write that Ellen White saw this or
that or the other the prejudice would be
too great will leave elegy white out of
the general papers those who judge of a
matter before they hear or unwise
support despise not prophesy and prove
all things hold fast that which is good
so basically they say Church we know
there is a prophet but don't say
anything to the outside world they're
not ready
for it we believe that God is
unchangeable that is the same yesterday
today and forever and that it is his
will and purpose to teach his tried
people at this the most important period
in the history of God's people in the
same manners in the past but oh that
word but as many are prejudiced against
visions we think based at present not to
insert anything of the kind
in the regular paper you know what we
have so many ministers in our church and
even at our institutes of learning they
are told
don't use the spirit of prophecy in your
preaching keep it up don't mention it
because of prejudice there was a case
once where a lady had accepted the truth
she was a Turkish lady she was a Muslim
and we had an occasion while we were
traveling through Turkey visiting the
seven churches location where this lady
became so animated by the truth that she
was just bubbling over because as we
were traveling she was the tour guide by
the way we were explaining to what these
prophecies all meant and then one day
she contacted us and said she wants to
come to visit us in our country so that
she can learn more about these things
and she did and she came for a year and
she enrolled in one of the colleges and
there she wanted to become acquainted
with what Adventists believe and she was
told that she was not allowed to use the
spirit of prophecy now we had of course
not hidden these facts from her and she
had written many things
it was very disturbing to see how they
treated her if she used the spirit of
prophecy this was a convent and I was
horrified and we have so many ministers
who say don't don't talk about her don't
do this well they did exactly the same
thing here this book that you are
quoting from was once a prescribed what
happened I don't know what happened but
perhaps it should become a prescribed
book again so but as many are prejudiced
against visions we think best at present
not to insert anything of the kind in
the regular paper we will therefore
publish the visions by themselves for
the benefit of those who believe that
God can call fulfill his word and give
visions and the last days so there are
the testimonies that there on yourself
but don't use them in your sermons don't
preach to them in part about them in
public no don't use them just I mean I
hear it all the time
thus you into this announced policy the
review for four years was very nearly
silent on the visions said nothing
during this time only five lmg white
articles were published and even these
were in the form of excitations making
no reference to revelations this was in
marked contrast to the six L&G white
articles in eleven issues of present
truth issued during the 15 month period
from August 18-49 to November 18 15 each
of which frequent mention was freely
made of the vision although James White
stated his intention to issue other
numbers of the extra to supply the needs
of the believers we fail to find that
that this was done so the spirit of
prophecy was not preached to the general
public and eventually it wasn't even
preached to the church anymore that's
basically what happened here's his
declaration in the review of April 21
1851 James White announced
the readers of the paper his position in
regard to the place of the spiritual
gifts in the church and their perpetuity
but made no reference to Ellen White's
experience he made it clear that the
Bible alone was the test of faith and
duty but this did not preclude spiritual
gifts given to lead us to the Living
Word
yes it is true that the Bible and the
Bible alone is the test of dogma yeah
but it doesn't preclude the spirit of
prophecy but he didn't include any of
that the position that the Bible in the
Bible alone is the rule of faith and
duty does not shut out the gifts which
God set into the church to the reject
them is shutting out that part of the
Bible which presents them we say let us
have a whole Bible and let that and that
alone be our rule of faith and Duty
place the gifts where they belong and
all is harmony so yes the Bible talks
about spiritual gifts but we won't
mention them in public that's what they
stated what he said and we won't even
publish them anymore to the church
either one year later October 16 1855 in
meeting false charges elder white again
stated his position and this is what he
said there is a class of persons who are
determined to have it that the review
and it's conductors make the views of
mrs. white a test of doctrine and
Christian Fellowship it might be duty to
notice these persons on account of the
part they are acting which is calculated
to deceive some what has the review to
do with mrs. White's views the
sentiments published in its columns are
all drawn from the Holy Scriptures no
right of the review has ever referred to
them as authority on any point the
review for five years has not published
one of them its motto has been the Bible
and the Bible alone the only rule of
faith and duty and that's exact
see what people are saying today great
we don't need it in public discourses we
don't even need it
in sermons most people before they are
baptized don't even know yet I was in
fact baptized not knowing anything about
the spirit of prophecy which is
astounding right and I've told many
times how I came to discover them there
are marvelous stories in the world how
people discovered the spirit of prophecy
absolutely amazing so to illustrate his
uniform position through the years elder
white then quotes his first published
statement on the subject of the spirit
of prophecy in meeting the charge that
the denominational doctrinal position
was based on the visions he states it
should be there he understood that all
these views as held by the body of
Sabbath keepers were brought out from
the Scriptures before mrs. white had any
view in regard to them these sentiments
are founded upon the scripture as their
only basis well that is potty true
because they studied the Bible and they
crystallized the truths out of the Bible
but when they could go no further yes
this is when the spirit of prophecy okay
and helped so this is and when there was
sometimes an issue that they didn't know
which one yes the spirit of prophecy
would come correct so they get pointed
to the Bible and the the Bible was taken
as the determining factor but
nevertheless the spirit of prophecy did
play a role as to which one of the many
choices was the one to be followed so
while the positions set forth in the
1855 review and Herald on the
relationship of the spirit of prophecy
to the Word of God was sound it is clear
from the experience of those years
that the rather negative treatment of
the subject together with absence of any
of the visions from the columns of the
review led to a general lack of
appreciation of the gift we have the
same situation today everywhere almost
every Church in the world and to a
lowering of its place of importance in
the work the results of this course of
near silence was not at once perceived
but at a General Conference of 1855 held
in Battle Creek commencing November 16
it was clear that all was not right a
realization of this led to confessions
relative to the evident departure of the
remnant from the spirit of the message
and the humble straightforward course
taken by those who first embraced it it
may be noted in this connection that
there had been a partial withdrawal of
the prophetic gift from the believers
writing of this shortly afterwards Ellen
White stated mothers is fascinating the
visions have been of late less and less
frequent and my testimony for God's
children has been gone I thought that my
work in God's cause was done and that I
had no further duty to do but to save my
own soul and carefully attend to my
little family so for virtually five
years there was no spirit of prophecy
yes why difficulty recognized and
remedied recognizing that the right
attitude had not been taken by the
church towards the spirit of prophecy
the Brethren assembled in conference at
Battle Creek passed the following formal
action at the Business session of the
General Conference and they chose Joseph
Bates and Wagner and Cornell to be on
this committee in Albany with this
action a comprehensive address was
prepared which expressed the convictions
of the conference we quote a few
paragraphs
which present the most significant
picture number one confession in view of
the present low state of the precious
cause of our Blessed master we feel to
humble ourselves before God and confess
our unfaithfulness and departure from
the way of the Lord we're by the spirit
of holiness has been grieved our own
souls burdened and an occasion given to
the enemy of all righteousness to
rejoice over the decline of faith and
spirituality amongst the scattered flock
if you neglect the spirit of prophecy in
the remnant movement you will lose it so
if we live in the times that we are
living in and the world needs here the
great controversy shouldn't reduce the
great controversy to the size of a
postage stamp or should we hand out the
great controversy or at least the
chapters dealing with the present
situation I think we should not be
ashamed and put our light under a bushel
if God has said that the remnant church
has a profit there should we be ashamed
of that fact for five years they were
ashamed and the result was there was no
more spirit of prophecy
they also said no have we appreciated
the glorious privilege of claiming the
gifts which our Blessed master has
vouchsafed to his people and we greatly
fear that we have grieved the spirit by
neglecting the blessings already
conferred upon the church we have also
in our past experience been made to
rejoice in the goodness of our God who
has manifested his care for his people
by leading us in his way and correcting
our errors through the operation of the
Spirit if we are not to preach these
things in the church then how will new
people sitting in the church or even out
people members in the church become
acquainted with these things how will
they know their duty
you know there's a statement which says
that the spirituality of the Church will
sell them rise above the norms and
standards of the pastors and if the
pastors neglect their duty to be an
example and to put the principles as God
has directed in the testimonies into
action then the public the members of
the church should take it into their own
hands
they should study for themselves and
implemented then if they are mocked for
it then being ashamed because Christ
endured the same yes we have also in the
past experience been made to rejoice in
the goodness of our God who has
manifested his care for his people by
leading us in his way and correcting our
errors through the operation of his
spirit and the majority of Sabbath
keepers in the third angels message have
firmly believed that the Lord was
calling his church out of the world and
us by means appointed to bring us to
unity of the faith this is so
importantly we refer to the visions
which God has promised to the remnant in
the last days what will bring unity to
the church unity around the spirit of
prophecy absolutely if you study the
spirit of prophecy which has very clear
directives and you say this is the will
of God help me to implement it in my
life and everybody else does the same we
don't get be honest I don't have any
confusion about what the Bible teaches
you won't have people sitting and
arguing me and you arguing no but the
Bible means this the Bible means this
we've got a guide we've got the
testimonies it shows you this is what
the Bible meant so then we can have
unity around it absolutely I mean in the
beginning remember somewhere in the one
of the testimonies that I've read they
were
together and she wrote that there wasn't
one in two persons that were unified on
anything exactly and we have the same
situation you today not to take the
place of the Bible nor do we as some
content exalt these gifts or their
manifestations above the Bible on the
contrary we test them by the Bible
making it the great rule of judgment in
all things so that whatever is not in
accordance with it in its spirit and its
teachings we unhesitatingly reject but
as we cannot believe that a fountain
sends forth at the same place sweet
water and better or that the evil tree
brings forth good fruit so we cannot
believe that that is of the enemy which
tends to unite the hearts of the science
to lead to meekness and humility and
holy living and insights to deep heart
searching before God and a confession of
our wrongs
whenever I have preached in the world
and there was conflict it was based on
our understanding of the spirit of
prophecy either directly or indirectly
by implementation of what it is said you
see this is why I think no now I don't
think I know that this is why the
shaking will be caused by the straight
testimony absolutely because once
everybody is out that doesn't want to
unify around the test the testimonies to
the church or the Prophet to get you
back to the Bible they will be out and
the rest will unify on the spirit so the
spirit of prophecy will cause the
shaking and will cause the unity and
will cause the unity and to world cause
the lot cry yes because as that receive
and in saying this we're not saying that
now Jesus is going to be on the back
foot and they're all viable because you
are United around the testimonies and
this this will take you in unity to G
absolutely anywhere everybody will be
united in the true testimony of Jesus
till we pray to the spirit of prophecy
know Jesus the Prophet know who do you
worship Jesus Christ the one who is
exalted because it is the testimony of
the true witness or the testimony of
Jesus Christ who is the true witness and
there was another point and a dispute
displeasing to God while we hold these
views as emanating from the divine mind
we would confess the inconsistency which
we believe has been displeasing to God
of professed League regarding them as
messages from God and really putting
them on a level with the inventions of
men she was influenced by the margin she
was influenced by Usher she was whatever
either she said it or she didn't say it
I think it was God who said it what was
the devil who said it can't be
half-measures we fear that this has
resulted in an unwillingness to bear the
reproach of Christ this is a fascinating
statement so if you say that you believe
the spirit of prophecy many people who
will reproach you and call you whatever
sect or whatever which is indeed greater
riches than the treasures of Earth and a
desire to conciliate the feelings of our
ponents but the word and our experience
have taught us that God is not honored
noise cause advanced by such a course
while we regard them as coming from God
and entirely harmonizing with his
written word we must acknowledge
ourselves under obligation to abide by
their teachings and be corrected by
their admonitions to say that they are
of God and yet we will not be tested by
them is to say that God's will is not a
test of rule for Christians which is
inconsistent and absurd and what was the
result of this con
the result was that there was a complete
turnaround they again published her
views to the public the church
flourished the visions returned and
Ellen White gave a revelation November
20th while in prayer the Spirit of the
Lord suddenly and powerfully came upon
me and I was taken off in vision I saw
the Spirit of the Lord has been dying
away from the church it is of special
interest to observe in this connection
that the matter revealed in this
important vision was published by action
of the Battle Creek Church and
constitute the first of the testimony
series so when they set the record
straight when they weren't ashamed of
the spirit of prophecy that's when God
wrought and the entire testimony series
saw the light I have always believed
that if something is truth it must be
able to stand on its own merits and
instead of hiding it make it prominent
in the past when evangelism was done you
very very carefully approached the
subjects and by the time you got to the
nitty-gritty the hall was empty face it
head-on say what the issue is come right
out and say God said remember the
Sabbath day the Church of Rome says I am
above the Bible I command you to keep
the first day of the work you have the
attention of the people immediately of
course some might be angry but they you
still have their attention then a few
weeks later a reassuring message from
Ella white appeared in the review at our
lake conference at Battle Creek God
wrote for us the minds of the servants
of God were exercised as to the gifts of
the church and if God's frown had been
brought upon his people because the
gifts had been slighted and neglected
there was a pleasing prospect that his
smiles would again be upon us and he
would graciously and mercifully revive
the gifts again and they would live in
the church to encourage the desponding
and fainting souls and to correct and
reprove the earring I am convinced that
it is time that the church follows a
similar course to the early church they
neglected it for five years we have
neglected it for decades and the result
is that every wind of doctrine is
blowing in the world every form of
apostasy has been thrown at us
churches are divided some going
completely the way of the world
totally rejecting the spirit of prophecy
we have magazines that make it their
business to do nothing but denigrate it
and run it down and it's time that God's
people stood up yes and that at least
that portion which is to receive the
loud cry goes on its knees and confesses
before God and says we have sinned by
neglecting a gift that you have given to
the remnant Church exactly do you agree
with that now our under forcing you're a
new Atlantis this is something wrong
with you response from the Battle Creek
Church now they absolutely learnt their
lesson in that early church right see
let's have a look if they good so this
was in 1955 so let's go to 1867 that's
just 10 years later a little bit more
than 10 years later they had exactly the
same thing again it faded so there is
this tendency for the spirit of prophecy
to be sidelined because it is
so uncomfortable to preach about these
thing so by 1867 led to right again
where they'd like to listen for the
second time we have learned by painful
experience also that when these
testimonies are silent or they're
warning slightly regarded coldness
backsliding worldly mindedness spiritual
darkness takes position of the church do
we have a similar situation today yes we
would not give glory to man but we
should be recreant to our sense of duty
not to speak in strong and pointed
language our views of the importance of
these testimonies the fearful apostasy
of those who have slighted and despised
them has furnished many sad proofs of
the dangerous business of doing despite
to the spirit of grace this is a
description of the times we are living
in this is a perfect description of the
state of the church worldwide yes
backsliding worldly mindless spiritual
darkness that is the course rejection of
the testimonies yes and who are the
people that for a second time are
speaking here the same people who spoke
in the first one look at them Jane
Andrews Loughborough Bates board of
Hutchins Byington and then later Uriah
Smith amadon and the elders they had a
tendency to have the high ground and
then go back down to the low ground and
we have the same distances so it is
human nature and rebellion against what
God once has been well the story of the
Bible you can just read what the Old
Testament says but brothers and sisters
I would make an appeal to the church to
return back to the pillars of the faith
and to put the testimonies back where
they belong now is the time not it has
to be done now we are living in the
times when this has to be done now if we
want to get the message of Jesus to the
world
is it possible that some people might
think that they can modify the spirit of
prophecy differently let's see what she
had to say what about changing the
spirit of prophecy
she says they come to me those that are
copying my writings and say now he is
the better revised words so we'll change
your wording and I think I'll put that
in don't you change one word not a word
the revised edition that's of her
writings we do not need at all we have
got the word that Christ has spoken
himself and given us and don't you in my
writings change a word for any revised
edition there will be revised editions
plenty of them just before the close of
Earth's history and I want all my
workers to understand and I've got quite
a number of them I want them to
understand that they are never to take
the revised word and put it in the place
of the plain simple words just as they
are they think they are improving them
perhaps their thinking will put them
into modern language because people
don't understand you know what people
have dictionaries hmm I don't have to
tell me everything down why don't we
lift a bee why don't we lift everything
up why do we have to dumb everything
down my first language is not even
English and I read her books as it
stands and that's the way you should
read them they think they are improving
them but how do they know but that they
may switch off on our idea and give it
less importance than Christ means them
to have I think we should read them as
they stand I have more or less gone back
to the old old versions because I find
them uplifting have we the truth are we
living in the closing period of Earth's
history is Christ at the door these are
questions for us all to settle education
or
always to be high holy order and the
need is more imperative now than ever
before let's not go down let's bring
people up the removal of the faithful
from this world will soon be
accomplished then why not bring all the
energies of mind and soul into entire
consecration to God my appeal is to
return to the old ways let's return to a
rediscovery of the Word of God let's
feel like those people evolved who went
into the temple and found those dusty
volumes and said we have found the book
of the law and let's read them and let's
put dust on our heads sackcloth on our
bodies and say to God we have neglected
a gift that you have given to the
remnant we have neglected to preach it
from the pulpits we have neglected to
shout it to the people out there in the
world and as a result we are in the
state that we are in as the end draws
near and the work of giving the last
warning of the world extends it becomes
more important for those who accept
present truth to have a clear
understanding of the nature and
influence of the testimonies not to hand
out documents then we should not preach
it that we shouldn't use it in our
sermons in our discourses no it becomes
more important and this is a testimony
so who does it come from from God
it comes from God if it's the testimony
of the true witness then it comes from
God so it becomes more important so what
does this mean for those who accept
present truth to have a clear
understanding of the nature and
influence of the testimonies which God
in His Providence has linked with the
work of the third angel's message from
it's very rise in ancient times God
spoke to men by
mouth of prophets and apostle's in these
days he speaks to them by the
testimonies of his Spirit there was
never a time when God instructed his
people more earnestly than he instructs
them now concerning his well and the
course that he would have them pursue
never a time we have more information
than any previous generation we should
cherish it we should cherish us in this
fearful time just before Christ is to
come the second time God's faithful
preachers will have to bear a still more
pointed testimony than was borne by John
the Baptist a responsible important work
is before them and those who speak
smooth things God will not acknowledge
as his shepherds a fearful woe is upon
them it is time to give the clarion call
the final warning to humanity now it's
not a time to say oh we have to keep it
general I've seen sermons when I say
keep it general
don't cry wolf if Jeremiah hadn't cried
wolf
would the Kings eyes have been put out
if he had heeded the call absolutely not
no I think it is time that we get
together as a church in unity and the
only way this is going to happen is what
we've seen now if we can get around and
acknowledge that the testimonies that
comes straight from God we have to
implement and we have to say this is
from God and we have to acknowledge it
and accept that we have to be reproved
if it has to be that way you know what
my brother you're a young Adventist I
used to be a young Adventist but now
that was
and we know that there are people that
can use the spirit of prophecy like a
hammer but if you study it in its
context it is so balanced it's like the
Word of God like we've many times said
before and what a privilege when people
embrace it
and what a unity there is amongst
brethren like the Bible said it's like
oil dripping from Aaron's beard when
brothers are in harmony with each other
there is nothing in the world that can
bring harmony to this church
other than the spirit of prophecy and
I'm afraid that it will be the
instrument of the shaking device Timoney
says those are accepted and cling to it
and ask God to imprint the principles on
the heart well take their stand and the
rest according to the study will be
shaken out brothers and sisters would we
want to lose heaven in the time that we
are living in take your stand make a
decision follow the directives of God
make them part of your life they're not
a burden the yoke is light it will be a
manifestation of the power of God to the
world that will be irresistible and
thousands will accept the truth with
nowadays but one may God help us to
realize the gift that this church has
let's pray
Heavenly Father thousands upon thousands
upon thousands of words written down in
testimony given to the church as a gift
to lead people into the paths of
righteousness and to take them back to
the greater light Heavenly Father help
us to follow this directive to make it
our own and to be in harmony with each
other with the word and the principles
of Christ bless your church bless your
people and bless those out there who
have to become acquainted with this
special gift for the times in which we
are living in Jesus name Amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time